tout plutôt écartent pour l'instant
l'idée d'une indemnisation des victimes
de la molécule de chlordécone au moment
où les urgences débordent au moment où
les sargasses arrive sur nos côtes
bonjour jérôme viguier bonjour mon agent
on quelle entrée en matière pour vous
les mains dans le cambouis tout de suite
mais vous le saviez avant de venir
oui je crois que c'est pas une
découverte et
c'est pas non plus mon premier passage
en martinique je suis venu à peu près
déjà trente fois sur l'île à l'occasion
de missions surtout sur la cancérologie
et je connais assez bien les
problématiques de santé publique qui
qu'elle s'est il est confronté
vous êtes médecin vous devenez directeur
de la rs et vous avez dit dans france
antilles dernièrement que vous aimeriez
apporter une sorte de regard nouveau
être complémentaires par rapport à ce
qui avait été fait parfois ce qui avait
déjà été fait oui je crois que il ya
assez peu de médecins qui sont
directeurs des ars on est sept sur les
17 agences régionales de santé et je
crois que ça permet d'avoir une approche
un peu différente que des directeurs
d'hôpitaux qui sont souvent nommé à la
tête des ars ou que d'inspecteurs
généraux des affaires sociales qui sont
aussi souvent à la direction de ses
agences donc le but pour moi ça va être
effectivement de pouvoir apporter un
regard un peu plus médical un peu plus
santé publique sur ce qui se passe en
martinique et puis peut-être de trouver
d'autres voies pour améliorer les choses
du pragmatisme du pragmatisme et une
approche surtout papa je m'inscris dans
la continuité de ce qui a été fait mais
en souhaitant aller plus loin mouiller
la chemise et pouvoir trouver des
solutions en prenant les problèmes un
par un papa et sans prétendre faire une
grande révolution et tout régler en deux
coups de baguette magique je ne suis pas
un magicien gerwig et vous faites
allusion à l'éditorial de joie reporté
la semaine dernière jérôme viguier qui
dit pas de bâtisses me dit également le
contenu du porte monnaie il faudra faire
attention financer dans toutes les
missions qui vous sont confiées
alors c'est clair que je lancerai
générale de santé a une enveloppe
contrainte mais peut aussi sur certains
sujets aider les établissements aidés
les
les opérateurs aider les associations
que nous soutenons à aller chercher
d'autres financements des financements
complémentaires pour pouvoir étendre
leurs actions et les faire de façon plus
intense
alors forcément des priorités ont été
établies quels sont les vôtres
alors les priorités en martinique elles
sont aussi nombreuses quasiment que les
sujets qui est amené à traiter la rs on
a des problématiques sur l'eau avec
derrière la chlordécone des
problématiques sur les sargasses vous
l'avez évoqué et c'est la première fois
en martinique que je en avant
l'atterrissage que je vois des bandes
sargasses aussi énorme
au large des côtes il y a donc la
chlordécone elle même qui est un
problème important
vous dites chlordécone mais certains
préfèrent parler d'empoisonnement deux
plans d'accord déconne avec une
complicité d'état qui avait dit qu'il
ferait beaucoup et qui finalement
attendre avant d'agir
alors je crois pas que l'état attend que
ça et le préfet robin extrêmement motivé
sur le sujet et peut-être que c'est plus
un défaut de communication vis-à-vis de
la population sur l'ensemble des choses
qui sont faites en termes de science en
termes de recherche avec la possibilité
même de décontamination des sols avec du
fer qui permettrait de casser cette
molécule de chlordécone la surveillance
des femmes enceintes aussi pour éviter
que vraiment on peut soin de juger
d'analysé de jauger un an qu'on sait que
le peuple souffre on voit les
conséquences de cette molécule de
chlordécone ya une chose que l'on sait
ils ont démontré scientifiquement et
puis il ya des choses on rappelle que
vous êtes cancérologue a essayé le rire
médecin gastro-entérologue et
cancérologue et puis à d'autres choses
sur lesquelles il faut affiner le
diagnostic puis il ya des choses qui
sont un peu éloignés de la science et
qui circule beaucoup et qui doivent là
aussi être confortée de façon à savoir
ce qu'il faut faire derrière comment il
faut le faire et ne pas faire n'importe
quoi
vis-à-vis de populations qui sont
effectivement dans la tente est très
claire et qui est halak auquel il faut
proposer la bonne réponse la réponse la
plus adaptée
je prends l'exemple du cancer de la
prostate in fine et faut-il faire un
dépistage généralisé du cancer de la
prostate dans les antilles
sachant que lorsqu'on fait un dépistage
du cancer de la prostate pour 40% des
personnes qui sont dépistés on va leur
imposer un traitement qui va
potentiellement les rendre impuissant et
un continent alors que peut-être il
n'aurait jamais souffert de leur maladie
donc il faut pas voir seulement une
étape il faut voir l'ensemble de la
chaîne et ses conséquences y compris
pour les martiniquais c'est ça ton appel
pragmatisme du médecin je sais pas si
c'est ce qu'on a fait le pragmatisme et
c'est ce qu'on appelle la santé publique
très environnementale avec les s'engage
la brume de sable du sahara
comment y faire face là ce sont des
effets de la nature alors il ya d'un
côté comment y faire face d'un point de
vue
logistique et c'est vrai que c'est plus
à la main du préfet qu'à la main deux
agences régionales de santé
nous on est en charge de la surveillance
avec des analyses par des capteurs qui
détectent les gaz toxiques et qui nous
incite à vraiment aller vers les maires
pour qu'ils fassent évacuer parce que la
première la première intervention c'est
d'évacuer les sargasses pour éviter qu
elles pourrissent sur place et qu'elles
émettent ces gaz
et pourquoi la population à cette
pression que nous
on constate encore une fois on voit
certaines conséquences m'accable
manifestement la sonnette d'alarmé pâtit
réactiver assez fortement
alors je crois que c'est pas tout à fait
vrai la sonnette d'alarmé elle active et
très rapidement avec des capteurs qui
enregistrent en continu sur les
principaux sites d'échouages de lille
maintenant il ya la problématique de
fond et c'est vrai que la mer des
sargasses tout ce qui se passera à côté
du brésil et ces échouages qui sont de
plus en plus fréquents et qui sont de
plus en plus abondants pose un problème
de traitement de la source et de
réactivité lorsque les échouages ce
fonds mais au-delà de ça puisque moi ma
ma fonction et surtout sur les risques
sanitaires liés aux sargasses il faut là
aussi qu'on progresse on sait ce que ce
que donne une exposition aiguë d'avoir
ça sent mauvais ça sent l'oeuf pourri et
puis c'est des gaz irritants mais on
doit et c'est une attente de la
population aussi travailler à ce que
donne des expositions répétées mais pas
des expositions chroniques les sargasses
reste pas tout le temps et qui sont
comme ça itérative répéter dans le temps
plusieurs fois et il ya quatre projets
je crois de d'études de thèse en au chu
de la martinique qui se sont spécialisés
en spécialité sciemment pardon focaliser
dessus de façon à compléter aussi la
connaissance sur cette exposition s'est
agacé du coup de voir quelles sont les
mesures sanitaires à prendre et j'ai
envie gay vous disiez tout à l'heure que
tout est une question de communication
pourquoi ne pas dire directement
martiniquais et bien vous serez des
cobayes tout simplement pour la science
je crois pas qu'on puisse dire que c'est
des cobayes ont maîtrisé en fin on est
des cobayes quand ce à quoi on s'expose
et maîtrisée par quelqu'un l'a révélé
choisi doit malheureusement on choisit
pas alors l'autre gros dossier c'est ce
chu asphyxier financièrement avec le
personnel volontaire
le personnel volontaire mais désorienté
et épuisée qu'elle peut être votre
action là dessus
alors je crois que déjà l'action
l'action de la rs avec mes prédécesseurs
d'appui au chu elle a commencé depuis
longtemps il ya de multiples missions
d'appui sur ce chu qui est effectivement
étrangler financièrement et qui paye en
fait certains certains choix
structurelles qu'un qui ont été faits je
crois qu'il faut là aussi avoir une
politique raisonnable du pape à se fixer
des objectifs atteignables et plus que
et une fois de plus je ne suis pas
magicien le chu de la martinique va pas
être remis d'équilibré financier
en deux jours il faut se fixer une
trajectoire raisonnable mais ambitieuse
c'est la république lors de son dernier
passage vers 6h unique aux antilles je
crois pas que ça soit exactement des
propositions complémentaires
voilà et mais justement c'est d'être un
peu plus sans complémentaire de pas
forcément multiplier les filières dans
chacune des deux îles outre on par
exemple comme ça par le cyclotron
problème récurrent le choix était fait
il avoue que c'est comique cette
histoire c'est assez je sais pas si
c'est si ces comics après moi mon au
tragique
mon rôle est de que les martiniquais
accès aux équipements dont ils ont
besoin en avec des délais d'intervention
qui soient les plus courts possibles la
martinique reste candidate à
l'installation d'un cyclotron c'est
marqué dans son programme régional de
santé
la guadeloupe a pu bénéficier avant nous
de cet équipement maintenant il faut
voir
entre les deux il si la cardiologie la
filière de cardiologie interventionnelle
elle est en martinique certaines
filières peuvent être en guadeloupe le
tout et quand même d'éviter qu'on met
des gens dans des avions pour aller se
faire traiter à paris c'est dans votre
feuille de route par exemple qu'on cette
complémentarité entre les chu mutualisés
pour être plus efficace et dans votre
feuille de route
l'idée est d'être face à des synergies
entre les deux établissements de
complémentarité et au delà des
établissements dans le domaine de la
santé sur les deux îles on doit
travailler ensemble sur les sargasses
ont exposé de la même manière on doit
travailler ensemble sur la chlordécone
on est exposé de la même manière est ce
qu'on a besoin
de chacun réinventer le fil à couper le
beurre de chaque côté ou est-ce qu'on
peut pas justement mutualiser les
intelligences les compétences de façon à
avoir des réponses qui seront déployés
sur les deux îles mais qui peuvent être
réfléchi entre les martiniquais et
guadeloupéens l'a d'ailleurs question
donc et finalement il faudrait d'une
agence régionale de santé antillaise
s'est pas actuellement à l'ordre du jour
mais en tout cas je vais renforcer et
j'en ai déjà discuté avec ma collègue
qui est médecin aussi de la guadeloupe
on va renforcer nos collaborations nos
synergies dans le dans le cadre du
travail
un terril est en fait zonal de la race
et juste comme ça juste pour susciter
quelques réactions ce siège une ars qui
travailleraient davantage la tête de
pont ce serait 3 pointe à pitre fort de
france
je réponds à cette question merci jérôme
viguier d'avoir été ce matin avec nous
rappelle que vous êtes le tout nouveau
régime directeur de l'agencé régionale
de santé et vous avez dit souvent
connaître pas magicien merci
[Musique]